this video sponsored by movement watches
and sunglasses more on movement at the
end of this video
hey wisecrack jared here today we're
talking about the story of a guy who
takes down the finance industry as he
talks to imaginary friends that's right
mr. robot mr. robot follows hoodie
Claude hacker Elliot Alderson as he and
his buddies instigate a revolution and
take down equally a fictional mega
corporation that's the gold standard of
corporate malevolence
a conglomeration of Bank of America
Walmart and Enron also Elliot's crazy on
the surface mr. robot is a show
criticizing capitalism some other type
of money makes you question right and
wrong but to really understand mr. robot
we have to dig deeper into an idea that
is woven into the very fabric of the
show alienation alienation means to be
estranged and isolated in the parlance
of mr. robot disconnected philosophy
deals with different kinds of alienation
there's alienation from humanity from
the world and even personal alienation
where you've become a stranger to
yourself mr. robot explores them all was
honest wisecrack Edition on the
philosophy of mr. robot oh and spoiler
alert mr. robot is about lonely people
trying to connect sometimes that means
quite literally connecting illegally to
other people's computers agent dip hero
has no life have no life and struggles
to connect with both strange men on the
internet and her Amazon Alexa Elliot
struggles to connect with his family his
past his friends and even reality and
the masses according to Elliot can only
connect to each other through facebook
Instagram and LinkedIn the show even
employs visual tricks to emphasize the
distance between characters such as
wide-angle lenses and framing characters
near the edge of the screen
Elliot's inability to connect is caused
by more than just his social anxiety or
that he talks to his dead father instead
Elliot's alienation has everything to do
with God let me explain Elliot is unable
to understand his actions his motives or
even his relationship to other people
mr. robot takes charge of Elliot's
physical body interacting with people on
his behalf
all while Elliot is complete
be unaware that anything is transpired
as a result Ellie is unable to
understand his relationship with sister
Darlene or anyone else he might have
interacted with as mr. robot and Wiley
it's psychosis makes his alienation from
himself and others unique the logic that
dictates that psychosis is nearly
universal for German philosopher Ludwig
Feuerbach whose name means firestream
but I digress
God was the primary engine of alienation
during the 19th century humans created
the figure of God according to lawyer
Bach and instilled him with their
highest ideals justice love wisdom and
so on but being a forgetful species they
forgot looked at this virtuous God and
said hey where's so much like this guy
he made us just like him in this way the
fact that man made God in man's image is
inverted - God created man in God's
image as a result christianity is
alienated we become estranged from our
ideals ourselves and each other because
we can only relate to them through the
medium of God a figure that we've sensed
lost control of if this seems strangely
familiar it should Eliot creates the
figure of mr. robot forgets he created
him and then goes about letting mr.
robot run his life in good Feuerbach Ian
fashion Elliott says mr. robot has
become my god and even creates mr. robot
in his own crazy image mr. robot is even
likened to an omniscient God always
watching mr. robot he ever-present
silent observer Elliott's first response
to the problem of mr. robot is to get
rid of him he pumps himself full of
adderall and starts journaling in the
hopes that he can kill him off this in a
way parallels the Atheist response to
God I don't listen to my imaginary
friend why the should I listen to yours
we invented God now we realize it
so let's dump him but Elliot's therapist
convinces him that the answer isn't to
dump mr. robot it's to accept his
delusion as part of it at this point I
think we have to accept
fact that he is the legitimate existence
in your life for Feuerbach the biggest
problem isn't that we invented God it's
that we inverted our relationship to God
and said he created us I'm always
supposed to be a prophet you're supposed
to be my god
or Bach thinks that God is the ultimate
object of thinking man
a creation that speaks to the unlimited
potential of our reason
similarly mr. robot represents Elliott's
highest ideals creating a better future
without evil Corp one of the big issues
with alienation is the loss of
responsibility you know the old I don't
hate you God does wasn't me Elliot
either suppresses the memory of the
unpleasant acts he has to commit in the
name of a better future
like allegedly killing a guy or imagines
mr. robot is responsible in the process
Elliot is unable to directly relate to
the world he helps shape or his peers
and instead has to relate through the
medium of mr. robot hey it's only when
Elliot admits that mr. robot is his own
creation that he can finally carve a
path out of his own alienation mister
when we've mixed up the relationship
between God and the world around us the
world becomes confusing cause-and-effect
seemed to invert themselves reality
slips away and we lose touch with our
fellow man no longer are we the drivers
of our fate but events are laid out by
the divine or your imaginary friend
we're no longer the judge of our actions
or the actions of others God is the rest
of the world doesn't see mr. robot but
that doesn't stop the show from drawing
an explicit connection between Elliot's
delusions and bears
don't tell me about not being real while
mr. robot maybe Elliot's God the masses
have a different God consumerism which
brings us to eight different kind of
alienation
show creator sam ishmael holds nothing
back in paying homage to other films
critical of consumer culture aside from
the obvious Fight Club and V for
Vendetta references one scene evokes
John Carpenter's they live a film
exploring the truth behind modern
capitalism and tyrell wellick is one big
ode to American Psycho a film where
people become as disposable as commodity
sorbet likewise one of these central
tenants of mr. robot is that consumer
culture is a collective delusion one
that estranges us from the world and
each other when mr. robot reminds
Elliott that nothing is real he says in
season 1 Elliott decides to be normal by
hearting things on Instagram watching
Marvel movies and drinking Starbucks
Starbucks throughout the show material
items and wealth is strange people from
their true selves whenever Angela Moss
is confronted about her working for evil
Corp for instance she defends her
character with displays of wealth when
she goes to buy a new pair of shoes to
replace a pair covered in her co-workers
brains the salesman confronts her saying
tell me I don't know who you think
you're talking to but I'll try the
Pradas next when again confronted at a
bar by her father's friend she responds
in 27 and I've got a six-figure salary
at the biggest conglomerate in history
and I'm just getting started if Angela's
motives seem unclear to the viewer
they're probably also unclear to her an
estranged world is a disorienting war
Angela who stresses she needs the job
evil Corp officer is in the same flight
as the guy who has to euthanize dogs for
a living
SiC betting on me I gotta pay the bills
or the homeless guy who allows Tyrell to
beat him senseless while wearing
sterilized surgical gloves in prison
Leon can only relate to Elliot with the
prison's DVD collection namely Seinfeld
a show about nothing a human condition
is a state of tragedy because in all of
these cases mass culture and commodities
inhibit our very being advertising and
media encourage us to destroy a part of
ourselves to fit in you destroy parts of
ourselves every day we Photoshop our
Ward's away annihilation is all they are
it sells us prepackaged narratives about
love and life for Elliot only when we
destroy the alienating forces of
consumerism can we finally be free we
will find our true selves again maybe
after wiping away the thick grimy film
of Facebook friend requests and vine
stars thus mr. robot shows another kind
of alienation commodity fetishism
commodity fetishism works a lot like
fire box alienation and it should its
creator Karl Marx appropriated fire box
work for his own ends
for Marx instead of God mediating human
relations commodities do we imbue
commodities with abstract value in such
a way that everything becomes
commodified for tyrell wellick every
interaction is an exchange even going so
far as to use his own body in pursuit of
greater well in the case of the
washington township trial the people who
died as a result of evil corpse actions
were treated as mere commodities profits
are more important than people's lives
it's for the same reason that evil
corpse executives can so easily forgive
kobe after he testified against them
every action isn't some indicator of
your character but an exchange of goods
and services in the same vein philip
rice hires
angela despite the fact that she
blackmailed but what exactly are the
stakes of alienation in the world of mr.
robot its control for both firebox and
marx the world is the object of
collective human labour a labour that
affirms our species being or our
membership to the human race
alienation destroys that species being
because the world that we collectively
build together has now been hijacked by
someone or something else it's no
surprise then that every character from
Angela - Elliott - Tyrell - price and
minister Zhang are vying for control
you've brought up this issue before this
issue of not feeling like you're in
control the series even opens with a
monologue about the people who have the
real control in society secret board
meetings control who lives and dies /
shrimp cocktails so you were drunk
eating shrimp cocktail and it was
raining when you decided my mother would
die young people are racked with debt
forcing them into jobs they hate and
Elliot can't stop the voice in his head
from taking over his life Minister Zhang
is obsessed with time surrounding
himself with clocks if only to remind
him of the one thing he can't control -
but a walking shadow a poor player that
struts and frets his hour upon the stage
and then is heard no more you surrounded
yourself with the constant reminder of
mortality Elliot is seen constantly
scribbling in his notebook about control
or fighting for control with mr. robot
he atributes shayla's abused by Fernando
Vera - the invisible hand the economic
forces that control her life there it is
again the invisible hand at work
controlling us even if it pushes this
past her threshold of pain in his
therapists office he likens the freedom
afforded by contemporary society to the
choice between Pepsi and Coke the real
question is where's the RC Cola both
Tyrell and Elliot blame their fathers
for their lack of control early on
Elliot blames his father for giving up
when evil core poisoned him about how
those bastards slowly killed your father
and how you wished he'd done something
about it but
didn't because he was a zero just like
you're being right now Tyrell never
wants to become his father whose
inability to speak English was a
reminder of his helplessness my father
used to say that to me all the time as a
childhood I was the only English she
knew the journal that Elliott
frantically writes about controlling is
aptly named red wheelbarrow Tyrells own
reminder of his father's impotence some
silly poem Terrell also likens murdering
Sharon Knowles to absolute power he and
others are really into playing God I
intend to leave a legacy the standard of
which was set by God Elliott at times is
unsure if he's mr. robots God or mr.
robot is his God in the end mr. robot
shows that nobody is really in control
in an alienated world the people at the
top have become victims of their own
machinations while they may try to
create an illusion of control with
armies of lawyers convoluted
conspiracies and bunker data centers
they all experience the same alienating
forces as the rest of society whether it
be in the form of God or commodity
fetishism conclusion mr. robot is not
only a show about lonely people trying
to connect it's about the engines that
drive that loneliness whether it's God
our imaginary friends or the things we
owned that engine distorts our
perceptions and turns a reality on its
head we can never really be sure what's
reality or delusion in mr. robot and
that's sort of the point in an alienated
world can we be sure that any kind of
reality exists thanks for watching guys
but whether you're in reality or hyper
reality you'll want to look good so if
you decided it's time to step up your
game with a new watch or new pair of
sunglasses you should check out movement
and if you're one of the first 200
wisecrack fans to make a purchase at MVM
t.com slash wisecrack using the offer
code wisecrack you'll get $15 off your
purchase founded on the idea that good
style shouldn't break the bank movement
cuts out the middleman giving you
designer great apparel at low prices
with their classic minimalist designs
and quality construction movements
watches keep you on time and in style
all starting at $95 and their sunglasses
are just cool they're lightweight
handmade and start at 70 bucks with the
OP
to polarize most pairs so head over to
MVM t-dot-com slash wisecrack or click
the link in the description be sure to
use the offer code wisecrack to get $15
off your purchase free shipping and
returns are included so join the
movement
thanks to movement for sponsoring this
video and we've got more great stuff on
the way for y'all including videos on
the exorcist saw stranger things and
lots more so if you haven't already
don't forget to click that subscribe
button it would mean a lot to me and my
dog catch y'all next time peace
[Music]